so übermorgen ist es soweit der suonntag
nicht eine nein zwei Landtagswahlen und
von wegen in Bayern ist es am spannsten
das wahre Drama findet ganz woanders
statt in diesem Sinne herzlich
willkommen zum heute show extra Spezial
leck mich fett und füll mich ab mit
eelby in fucking Hessen wird
gewählt jo ganz genau haltet mal alle
das Sabel und hockt euch ruhig auf der
Bobbes hannebumble ja er be die
hessewähle oder so ähnlich ich weiß es
doch nicht übrigens auch interessant für
uns nicht Hessen weil man ja erst
Sonntagabend weiß ob wir Nancy Feser als
Innenministerin behalten müssen er
dürfen meine ich ja ja im Moment weit
abgeschlagen hinter der CDU mit Minister
PRI Boris rin insgesamt muss man sagen
ja wirklich suboptimaler Wahlkampf von
der Nancy und selbst der Kanzler geht
auf Distanz also körpersprachlich haben
sie es gesehen hier die fäser setzt zum
Schmatz an und er so
nee noch mal noch mal die Zeitlupe um
Gottes
willm er denkt dann lieber kumex
Untersuchungsausschuss Liebe Nancy Z
mitschreiben nein heißt
nein so und falls Sie zu Hause jetzt mal
richtig blauen Bock haben auf noch mehr
low lights aus dem hessenwahlkampf da
hilft der hässische Rundfunk gerne aus
glauben sie an Aliens nein
überen musst du
gehen schmeckt auch
lecker für welchen Gegenstand haben sie
[Musik]
Gefühle super
Trooper
lassen Sie es mich mit aber sagen mama
mia was für ein
waterl ja tatsächlich gibt's gerade
viele spannende Themen echte Themen im
Hessen Wahlkampf Wohnungsnot
Lehrermangel Spaß interessiert Medi kein
Hering nein nein einziges Thema in
Deutschland inklusive Hessen ist
natürlich Migration ja man diskutiert
immer noch über Zahnärzte die den ganzen
Tag nur Taliban behandeln oder so
ja leicht überspitzt halt oder was hat
der März neulich gesagt die werden doch
wahnsinnig die Leute wenn die sehen dass
300.000 Asylbewerber abgelehnt sind
nicht ausreisen die vollen Leistungen
bekommen die volle Heilfürsorge bekommen
die sitzen beim Arzt und lassen sich die
Zähne neu machen und die deutschen
Bürger nebendran kriegen keine Termine
du wirst wahnsinnig 300000 abgelehnte
lassen sich den ganzen Tag goldene
Gebisse in den Kiefer
ballern gut tatsächlich
ausreisepflichtig sind 54 000 aber
trotzdem wichtig dass die CDU das mit
den Zähnen mal anspricht endlich od der
Zeit danach seitdem werden im Fernsehen
tagelang nur noch Zahnärzte geschaltet
zurecht weil es ja ein konkretes Problem
ist was jetzt ganz konkret die Zahnärzte
angeht ist es nicht so dass ich ih jetzt
sagen kann dass wir da ein großes
Problem haben ich mess das immer daran
kriegst du Briefe kriegst du keine
Briefe aus der
Bevölkerung und in dem Bereich ist es so
dass wir jetzt im Ministerium auch keine
Anzeichen haben dass das ein großes
Problem
ist
ja ich liebe einfach diesen
Münsterländer landwirtound mit der
Scheiße die der März labert kannst du
zwei Felder düngen
du so habe ich das sinngemäß übersetzt
natürlich gibt's große Probleme in den
Kommunen aber die löse ich ja nicht
indem ich Menschen mit Halbwahrheiten
gegeneinander ausspiele was macht der
März da Konrad adenuhaus Fragen schon
die ersten wohin mit Opa ja ja ich
fürchte ja bei ihm steckt gar keine
große Strategie dahinter oder ein ein
antifd Plan der freestyl einfach in
Interviews gibt's da nicht was von
ratiofarm immer mehr CDU Vorsitzende aus
dem Sauerland leiden unter einem
seltenen Problem nicht in freier Natur
aber in Interviews brechen Vorurteile
und halluzinierte Fake News
unkontrolliert und krampfartig hervor
über die kleinen Paschas genau oder über
einen sozialtourismus dieser Flüchtlinge
ja eklig aber dagegen hilft ab sofort
doppelmärz das Mittel gegen chronische
interviewi inkontinen und für nachts
gran Fritz endlich weniger disen
müssen er kann ja nichts
dafür
kanür sehen sich übrigens beim Thema
Migration geradezu nach pragmatischen
Problemlösung stattdessen kriegt man
Friedrich März sekundiert von CDU
Generalsekretär Carsten Linnemann oder
wie ich ihn liebevoll nenne den minimärz
ja ja ja war diesmal wieder so der arme
musste schon wieder in zich TV Studios
erklären wie sein Chef das angeblich
gemeint hat ist voll der Höllenjob viele
wissen das gar nicht aber wenn märz mit
seinem Hund im Sauerland Gassi geht
läuft Lindemann hinterher und und hebt
die Haufen auf ne an jedem Hochzeitstag
bringt Linnemann Frau märz den
Blumenstrauß und wenn März zunimmt muss
Linnemann natürlich Sport machen ne so
geht's nicht weiter deshalb die neue
heute show Aktion freelini meine Damen
und Herren gut ich meine eine
berechtigte Frage lautet wie lange
können wir uns unser Asylsystem noch
leisten wenn fast jeder der es hier hin
schafft am Ende bleiben darf warum sind
wir nicht weiter bei den
migrationsabkommen oder beim neuen
Türkei Deal den könnte doch mal der eine
hier Vorantreiben der Dings äh Olaf
Scholz genau ja dafür hatten wir den
noch angeschafft dachte ich ja natürlich
solche Deals wären viel wichtiger als
die ganze Sachleistung statt
bargelddebatte oder das Redigieren von
Texten die Ampel reformierte das
Aufenthaltsgesetz aus dem Zweck
Steuerung und Begrenzung wurde
Begrenzung gestrichen vor allem auf
Drängen der grün wie es hieß ja viel
besser so viel besser und ich sag mal
wenn es der Grünen Seele hilft warum
nicht jetzt braucht es Empathie plus
Realismus was absolut keiner braucht
meine Damen und Herren sind Ratschläge
von Elon Musk der diese Woche uns
Deutsche in einem Tweet aufruft die
Ampel abzuwählen wegen Geld für
Seenotrettung ja Elon Musk außerdem
wirbt er indirekt für die AFD twitter
ist unter mask inzwischen wirklich zum
asozialen Netzwerk geworden wo der Chef
persönlich verschwörungskram verbreitet
gut ich war da eh nie aber andere sind
regelrecht abhängig und brauchen
Hilfe
gernotasknecht braucht
hilfe Hallo mein Name ist Gernot und ich
bin twittersüchtig hallo und im Moment
bin ich echt stolz denn ich war jetzt
schon seit über 7 Stunden nicht mehr auf
Twitter me toxische Wut die Fake News
dieze das färbt ja auch ab ohne Twitter
bin ich direkt ein neuer Mensch viel
entspannter achtsamer weniger aggressiv
du es heißt aber nicht mehr Twitter das
heißt jetzt x halt die Fresse das ist
mir doch
scheißegal wo war ich ach ja weniger
aggressiv ich meine früher fand ich
Twitter auch okay ein harmloser Spaß so
wie ich auch dachte mask wäre nur ein
harmloser igomane der seine Mitarbeiter
zwingt zu jubeln wenn er tanzt wie ein
Einbeiniger Bär der sich in die Hose
gekackt hat aber an dem ist gar nichts
lustig auf Titter ist wieder alles
erlaubt inklusive Antisemitismus und das
heißt dann Meinungsfreiheit der
obertroll mischt sich inzwischen ganz
offen ein in die Weltpolitik diese Woche
verhöhnt er Präsident selenski und macht
Werbung für die die AFD mir reicht's ich
bin nur noch bei Facebook was den
Facebook unterbrich mich noch
einmal Elon Musk will die Weltherrschaft
woher weiß ich das er hat neulich das
hier gepostet sein Firmenlogo übernimmt
die Erde wie so ein verdammtes
alienraumschiff wisst ihr was ich lösch
jetzt meinen Twitter Account und geht zu
Blu Sky kein halbwegs vernünftiger
Mensch kann noch bei Twitter se Twitter
produziert nur Hass und Gewalt wie
gesagt eigentlich heißt das
X
gernecht braucht
hilfe
meine jetzt aber malönliche Frage waren
sie letzten Dienstag auch so wahnsinnig
ergriffen ja deutscher Feiertag der
Brückentag genau ja 3 Oktober oder wie
wir ihn traditionell nennen unser oss
pendence day ja diesmal gefeiert in der
Hamburger elbfilharmonie wo sie zum
Festakt natürlich wieder ausschließlich
die ganz großen reingelassen haben
unsere Legenden ne Otto Walkes klar dann
Olivia Jones logisch welcheer Arme Dödel
musste diesmal hinter der Perücke sitzen
ach so ja dann dann habe ich doch kein
Mitleid
der Schröder du ja gut wahrscheinlich
muss man den russischen Botschafter
einladen ich weiß es nicht ich weiß es
nicht Tag der Deutschen Einheit und 60%
der deutschen sehen in einer aktuellen
Umfrage eher das Trennende wie schade
echt schade denn z.B bei Renten und
Lebenserwartung nähern wir uns doch
immer mehr an was ist überhaupt noch
typisch Ossi oder typisch Wessi typisch
Wessi ist den dann typisch
WR da könen die schon krieg die Krise 11
ja ich s das heißt 3 und nicht
11:rr die spinnen doch da Wessis elende
uhrensöhne ja also Fakt ist ja
tatsächlich brauchen wir Wessis den
Osten und zwar um uns als die guten zu
fühlen dann guckt man z.B auf die
schlimmen AFD zahlen da und vergisst
dass die in baden-würtenemberg
inzwischen bei 20% stehen in
Ostdeutschland sind nur 39 pro der
Menschen mit der Demokratie zufrieden
richtig im Westen aber auch nur noch 59%
verstehen sie man gleicht sich schon an
bloß halt anders als gedacht ne und wo
hört überhaupt Demokratie auf und wo
fängt Diktatur an vor dem 3 Oktober
plädiert die Linken Politikerin Sara
Wagenknecht für eine Neubewertung des
Tags der deutschen Einheit ihrzufolge
stehen insbesondere die Grünen wie keine
andere Partei Zitat für eine
Übergriffigkeit die nicht ig ostdeutsche
an die DDR erinnern dürfte ja absolut ja
klar grüne und DDR das kannst in einen
Sack stecken ne ja im Grunde sind
Harbeck und bbock die neuen honckers ne
ja ja natürlich natürlich ja
verstörender Applaus an dieser Stelle ja
vielleicht ist es ja noch schlimmer
überleg mal die Bilanzen die DDR hat
ihre Bürger Jahrzehnte lang eingesperrt
bespitzelt Menschen erschossen die raus
wollten und die Grünen erlauben
Ölheizung nur noch bis
2045 ich würde sagen klares
Unentschieden oder ME ernsaft wie kann
man denn als ehemalige DDR Bürgerin
diesen Unrechtsstaat so verniedlichen
leider kein Einzelfall es fühlt sich
schon wieder so an wie in der DDR liebe
Freunde und dafür haben wir nicht die
friedliche Revolution gemacht liebe
Freunde das wollen wir nie wieder
erleben ja richtig abbn mein Gott haben
sie das gehört haben sie das gehört wir
haben eine Revolution gemacht sagt er
wir zur Erinnerung das Berny Bärchen war
1989 Achtung süße 17 Jahre alt Wohnort
rheinlandfalz ja tut aber so als hätte
er zusammen mit David hesselof die Mauer
aufgesungen ist doch wirklich alles nur
noch lächerlich ernsthaft ja na
ja dafür sind wir nicht auf die Straße
gegangen so zu den traurigen Tatsachen
in Ost und West steht die AFD gerade
blendend da und bestimmt den Diskurs in
Deutschland obwohl sie immer radikaler
wird na klar solange sie nicht verboten
sind kann man die wählen das nennt sich
Demokratie Klitz kleiner Haken unter
einer AFD Regierung könnten wir das gute
alte Grundgesetz sehr wahrscheinlich
bald zum Trödel geben ne oder zum Horst
keine Ahnung ne also ja meine bestimmte
Grundrechte würden dann vielleicht
bleiben aber natürlich nicht für jeden
fordert ein AFD Bundesvorstandsmitglied
das Verbot des Christopher Street dayss
für Sie zur Schaustellung sexueller
obstyitäten dann würde ich lieber sagen
ja die russische den russischen Weg eben
solche Organisationen fernzuhalten wenn
man irgendwas verbotenes tut muss man
damit rechnen dass eben die Polizei
kommt ja der russische Weg die Polizei
soll bei homosexuellen obstunitäten
einschreiten ne man könnte auch sagen
Verkehrskontrollen durchführen
und trotzdem halten
27% der deutschen die AFD für eine
normale Partei eine AFD in der es
überhaupt keinen Widerspruch mehr gibt
zum völkischen höckekurs auch nicht von
Frau Weidel Grüße nach Mallorca ja ja ja
ja wahrscheinlich müssen die sich auch
gar nicht mehr bürgerlich taren für
viele hat das Wort rechtsextrem offenbar
jeden Schrecken verloren dabei würde
Deutschland unter Reichskanzler höcke
sehr wahrscheinlich seine Westbindung
auf und Europa in Nationalstaaten
zerfallen woraufin er hier
[Applaus]
sagt genau hurr bzw ach du scheiße ja in
Umfragen spiegelt sich trotzdem weniger
die Angst vor einer aufziehenden
Diktatur als Wut auf eine angeblich
schon bestehende 67% sagen man wird in
Deutschland ausgegrenzt wenn man eine
bestimmte Meinung äußert und klar solche
Befunde muss die Politik schon ernst
nehmen nur ich sag mal Diktatur geht ja
eigentlich
anders du hast die Ampel und findest
dass Deutschland keine Demokratie mehr
ist du zeigst den Eliten gern die rote
Karte und bist ansonsten gegen wen noch
mal gegen
Merkel gut dirigiert zwar nicht mehr
aber egal Buch jedenfalls noch heute
dein freiwilliges autokratisches Jahr
und L mal Diktaturen kennen stell dich
mit einem Putin muss wegchild auf den
Roten Platz und lass dich überraschen
was passiert oder organisier den ersten
Christopher streetday in lasukaschenkos
Weißrussland der freut sich bestimmt das
freiwillige autokratische J jetzt buchen
gegen du weißt schon gegen
Merkel der
RE Bildungsreise
ja ich muss sagen ich find es irgendwie
schade dass vor allem beim Thema
Ostdeutschland immer nur über die lauten
und die wütenden geredet wird und eben
kaum über die zwei Drittel der
ostdeutschen die zur freiheitlichen
Demokratie stehen sollten wir dringend
ändern statt ständig wie das Kaninchen
auf die Schlange AFD zu glotzen das wird
doch am Sonntag garantiert wieder so
laufen wie stark werden die in Bayern
und Hessen so diese bange Frage leite
ich mal direkt weiter an den Kollegen
Albrecht Humbold vom Politbarometer in
Mainz Albrecht haben sie Zahlen für uns
nö kein Bock mach mir gerade käsef dü
bitte ja ich bin raus Feierabend mir ist
nämlich aufgefallen Umfragen sind Teil
des Problems irgendwelche Hongs die
warum auch immer tagsüber Zeit haben
wildfremden Leuten am Telefon Fragen zu
beantworten meinen irgendwas warum wird
darüber berichtet leck mich alle ja aber
ich meine sie sie sind doch
demoskop früher jetzt mache ich was
sinnvolles und zwar
käsefondu hier nur mal eine Handvoll
echte bildschlagzeilen aus den letzten
Wochen
umfrageschock für die Ökopartei AFD
überholt die Grünen nicht zu verwechseln
mit schockumfrage AFD holt Rekordzahlen
oder nächster Umfrage Hammer AFD
überholt sogar SPD nächstes Umfrage
Beben AFD in Thüringen schon bei
34% also ich rechne stündlich mit
schockbeben Hammer AFD AFD
AFD ich meine gut so eine schockierende
schockumfrage ist ja schon relevant eben
nicht eine reine Momentaufnahme das sind
weder Wahlergebnisse noch Steintafeln
die Moses vom Berg Forsa runter trägt
und wir vom ZDF Politbarometer sind da
übrigens kein bisschen besser mit
unseren komischen beliebtheitsrenking
ständig niemand kapiert
das davor Karl Lauterbach und Christian
Lindner -0,1 beide etwas besser als
zuletzt Robert habck gewinnt deutlich
dazu
jetzt hurra er hat dazu gewonnen und ist
jetzt bei
Null
Glückwunsch Beliebtheitsranking sind wir
auf Schulhof oder was also ich mag
denert viel als die S der guckt immer so
süß ach ja und wussten sie eigentlich
noch unbeliebter als März Wagenknecht
und Weidel ist nach neuesten Umfragen
nur noch abgelaufener Magerquark gefolgt
von Sonnenbrand in der
Kniekehle welke wir müssen uns mal
hinterfragen gefühlt jeden Tag eine neue
Umfrage die dann wieder andere
umfragen Umfragen beeinflusst und allein
die Fragestellung macht total viel aus
hier ich habe mal eine Umfrage für Sie
ich kann z.B fragen wie gefällt ihnen
die heutehow oder ich frage wann soll
der völlig talentfreie Oliver Welke
endlich abgesetzt werden a heute oder B
lieber
gestern ich glaube ich habe gerade doch
keine Zeit für Umfragen dachte ich mir
Mahlzeit Albrecht Humbold vielen
Dank die haben gesagt ich soll meinen
Lieblingswitz erzählen das ma ich gern
also kommen ein Pferd Chef besos und der
Papst in eine Bar sagt der Barkeeper
abonniere endlich den verkackten heute
sch Kanal also geht doch